oh
tu vois il faut pas ouvrir après les
gens ils viennent
savez que votre père a sauvé l'union
statut sans doute est ce qu'il peut
faire pour vous en fait je voudrais
construire une maison 61 elle avait déjà
d'or évidemment il faut dans un premier
temps que je dépose une demande de
permis de construire mais vous pouvez
pas lui accorder la hausse pas question
que je me bouge mon troupeau parce que
gmail vers bâle - il faudra bien sûr que
j'ai un entrepreneur pour la
construction
ces cas mais ça c'est moi pas de
problème j'ai un cousin qu'elle est
petite équipe c'est quoi ce mur soit pas
que plus tendue
c'est eux qui ont fait d'avoir raté de
monsieur gourdeau là bas où ça la wii
est rien et puisque maintenant on n'y
est plus je combats à skis si des fois
les maisons saisies sont et d'un coup et
ils sont plus
mais on m'avait dit que tous les
attentats des attentats non les
plasticages oui
[Musique]